what did you do here cherry tomatoes
cook with fresh herbs tons of flavor
olive oil mixed bless your white wine in
there please olive oil
I usually give a splash out of the
bottle Gary goes right out of there
whenever you're cutting you just want to
get everything to be the same kind of
size I've always found that the size it
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day size does not matter
now everybody at home you got
it okay this is really good salmon
Mike's asking a great question did we
wash the sand before we wash this out we
did not right no good nope which I
believe in I believe we wash too many
things in society I'm serious our immune
systems are not strong enough I'm not
washing anything again I eat everything
from the [__] dirt to be the next
book don't wash [__] come into the
bookstore when you're here